cinéma avec le nouveau film de jacques
doillon la vie de famille c'est
l'histoire d'un règlement de compte
amoureux entre un père et sa fille
cela se passe au cours d'un week end et
un week-end qui se transforme en un
grand voyage la fille plutôt tourmenté
c'est mara goyet le père tout aussi
tourmenté c'est ça me ferait ça me
ferait que l'on va retrouver dans
quelques instants compagnie d'henri
chapier les auparavant je vous invite à
regarder un court extrait de ce fil
henderson
ça c'est complètement con c'est toi qui
t'intéresse ktm avec je peux même pas
faire simplement la musique
pourquoi pas
on n'applique pas les singes
je dois une seule chose que tu aimes et
donc toi tu pourrais dire que c'est ok
bah si tu la trouves latine riders de la
planète victoire
très facile mais c'est loin même temps
que la carte
dans la cas
combien
maintenant j'espère que tu es un peu
importe quelle attitude
mais je connais une autre merveille
beaucoup plus près d'ici quoi quoi
quoi toi
savez frais comment peut-on arriver à
cette alchimie extraordinaire avec une
petite actrice de 11 ans et comment
peut-on l'installer cette atmosphère
parce que bon je sais que doyon laisse
toute liberté mais racontez moi un peu
comment vous l'avez installé
l'atmosphère avec elle tout au long du
film d'ailleurs
je crois que le mérite en revient à
jacques talent tout à fait
extraordinaire pour exploiter les
qualités naturelles d'un enfant c'est
sais pas pas évident pour un enfant de
tourner un film parce que dès le premier
jour
elle arrive devant la caméra il faut se
mettre à un endroit précis
il faut dire le texte il faut retrouver
sa véritable nature et ça c'est le grand
talent de jacques defer retrouvé à
l'intérieur d'une véritable fiction la
nature de la personne et l'identité de
la personne qui l'a détecté de la
personne au moment où il l'a choisie au
moment il a choisi cette petite fille
elle avait une certaine nature et on
retrouve la nature de la petite fille
transposé dans une histoire de fiction
par jacques mais il me semble qu'il a
bien su choisir le pape a également est
en fête
parlons si un peu sérieusement si vous
voulez de votre apport parce qu'il n'est
pas question de les passer vous avez
certainement éprouvé quelque chose parce
que il me semble que cette petite fille
ça traduit un peu les rapports de nous
autres adultes avec les femmes que
l'onem
évidemment tout en restant extrêmement
pur et c'est un rapport d'un type
nouveau dans la société actuelle le
rapport l'identité du père se cherche
or là dessus je crois que vous avez
quelque chose à me dire oui je je crois
que le
le personnage qu'a voulu jacques est un
homme qui est tout à fait insatisfait de
sa relation avec les femmes qui sont
autour de lui dire je crois qu'ils se
trouvent tout à fait insuffisant il est
insuffisant partout il est insuffisant
avec son ex femme il est insuffisant
avec sa fille pour qu'ils votent pour
les week-ends ou lui proposent que des
choses une banalité d'un ennui colossal
style télévision déjeuner avec la
grand-mère toutes choses sont d'un ennui
formidable et dont il a conscience il a
conscience est insuffisant et il veut
marquer je crois le le passage de
l'enfance à l'adolescence par quelle
part eu un rapport qui soit beaucoup
plus réelle entre cet enfant et lui et
il essaie d'avoir une véritable
explication même de deux cas c'est
l'univers de l'enfant de rentrer dans
son univers de de labrusse qui est de
devenir lui même complètement infantile
mais pour avoir une véritable
explication pour passe pour passe partir
je vais probablement arriver à le dire
sur de nouvelles bases avec elle pour
que son adolescence soit quelque chose
de plus nettes de plus exacte dont le
rapport qu'elle peut avoir avec son père
l enregistrement l'apothéose c'est la
femme de mabri dans l'hôtel c'est
pratiquement très délicat ça evga votre
avis et ça peut être perturbant pour cet
enfant dans la vie comme au cinéma il
reste quelques je crois qu'à la fin elle
était arrivée avoir une véritable
distances avec son personnage
ce qui n'a pas été le cas pendant tout
le film où elle était excessivement
appliquée l'intérieur de ce qu'elle
faisait
et si elle n'avait pas le goût de faire
quelque chose elle ne le faisait pas on
a changé par jacques et le sénat risque
et jean françois boyer son père et moi
même qui suis intervenu un petit peu a
certainement avons changé beaucoup de
choses dans le scénario c'est mieux
l'action c'est beaucoup plus concentrés
autour des deux personnages autour de
leurs problèmes alors juste en un mot
pourquoi voit-on si rarement quand même
ça me ferait il ya une question de choix
de sélection dans vos projets c'est pour
ça je suppose il faisait je préfère que
vous ne lisiez qu'on a trop rarement
plutôt qu'on va trop souffre peut-être
qu'effectivement il ya
il n'y a pas beaucoup de portes unités
aussi formidable que celle que j'ai eue
avec jean merci l'ami vrai c'est moi